factor x squared - 49 y squared so
what's interesting here is that well x
squared is clearly a perfect square it's
the square of X + 49 y squared is also a
perfect square it's the square of 7y so
it looks like we might have a special
form you're going to remind ourselves
just think about what happens if we take
a plus B times a minus B I'm just doing
it in the general case so we can see a
pattern here
so over here for you this would be a
times a which would be a squared plus a
times negative B which would be negative
a b plus b times a or a times b again
which would be a b and then you have B
times negative B so it'd be minus B
squared
now these middle two terms cancel out
negative a B plus a B they cancel out
and you're left with just a squared
minus B squared and that's the exact
pattern we have here we have an a
squared minus B squared so this is going
so in this case a is equal to X and B is
equal to and B is equal to 7 y so we
have x squared minus 7y the whole thing
squared so we can expand this as the
difference of as the difference of
squares or is actually this thing right
over here is the difference of squares
so we can expand this like this so this
will be equal to x plus 7y x plus 7y
times x minus 7y and once again we're
just pattern matching based on this
realization right here if I take a plus
B times a minus B I get a difference of
squares this is a difference of squares
so when I factored it must come out to
the result of something that looks like
a plus B times a minus B or X plus 7y
times X minus 7y